طبعا احنا بقول في ارض الرباط مما هد
بيوتنا قتل اطفالنا قتل شيوخنا احنا
صامدين احنا صامدين في ارضنا ليوم الدين
ماما العدو الصهيوني فلسطين لازم تتحرر هي
اح فلسطين في قلبنا فلسطين لازم تتحرر
العدو الصهيوني المجرم الموت اليوم
لنتنياهو وابن غفير وكل التحيه لا لاهلنا
في الطفه الغربيه مزيدا من عمليات الضفه
احنا في غزه نحي المقاومه نحيي المقاومه
اللي بتطق على الصهاينه على الدبابات يوم
بتاله من الصهاينه ماما هد بيوتنا احنا
الله موجود احنا الله معان مش حنتنا ازل
عن قضيه الفلسطينيه نحيي المقاومه نحيي
حماس فتح الجهاد كل الفصال وطالب منها
الانقسام ونتوحد الى تحرير فلسطين احنا
كنا مجروح شهاده وحسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل
حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل احنا باق على
الارض الشيخ زايد وكل فلسطين وحسبنا الله
ونعم
الوكيل